- It's a warm, lovely day,
and I'll try to keep us all
awake if I can (laughs).
And our reward at the end of this,
at the end of this lecture
will be a reception to be held outside.
So, let's rock and roll.
Our topic tonight is
sustainable stewardship.
And if we could have the lights off,
it'll assist us all in
sleeping more soundly.
(audience laughs)
And I'll be taking pictures
of those who nod off and
(audience laughs)
posting it on the Internet.
I got, uh.
Before I actually get
into this talk, though,
if you will indulge me
for five quick minutes,
I know that there's folks here,
many of you that are involved in graphics,
and in paper conservation, and
photographic-related matters.
If I could just put that other hat on
for just a moment,
I wanted to take just five minutes
to familiarize you with
something that we are
very proud of at the
Image Permanence Institute
that we have created as
a learning and teaching,
primarily teaching, tool for
the identification and understanding of
graphics materials, images on paper.
Starting back from wood-block prints
and going forward to the
latest digital materials.
And, in other words, it's process ID.
It's a teaching tool for process ID.
And it's to be found on the web at
GraphicsAtlas, one word, dot org.
And this is Graphics Atlas.
And I'll give you just
the briefest tour of it.
Everything on Graphics Atlas
is arranged around processes.
You see you got pre-photographic,
photomechanical,
photographic, and digital.
And within each one, for example,
within photographic processes,
there are individual examples.
And you can browse them by name
if you already know that you wanna,
you wanna explore
chromolithograph, you can.
Or there's a visual
browser, where you can say,
"Does my thing look like this?"
So, if your thing's a mezzotint,
you think, yeah, okay,
let's explore the mezzotint.
And that takes you to
one of the three ways
to look at each individual material.
This is called the guided tour.
And the guided tour has selected images
that tell you about this particular
graphic object that you're looking at,
and things to notice about
it, the prominent features.
So you can click through them, and
etched lines, the
characteristic rocker marks,
and markings of the mezzotint, and so on.
You can look at a little
video of the surface,
when it works.
Ah, yeah, there you go.
All the materials, there's a
little video back and forth.
Mezzotints are matt surface,
and have no reflections.
So if it were glossy, you
would be able to see that,
it's a bit analogous to
holding it in your hand.
And there's a neat little thing here
where you can click full-screen.
All of those things,
all of those views in the guided tour,
you can click through one by
one and see it full-screen.
So, that's the guided tour.
And you can also do something
called compare view,
where you can compare
one process to another.
So, if you wanted to
compare a mezzotint with,
oh I don't know, let's see, a cyanotype?
(laughs)
What you'll see is there's this,
there's a dimension bar that shows you
every image on this, and
you'll see that there are
about 22 images of each process, can be,
they're made in exactly the same way.
So in the compare view, there's a little,
there's a little driver's console here,
where you can control whether you're
looking at the front or the back.
You can change the angle of light,
so if you wanted raking light
to see the texture, you can do that.
You can do different magnifications.
And you can also see cross-sections
labeled with each one.
For example here in the, in the cyanotype,
you see the ferricyanide
image in the paper fibers,
and there's the ink on
the mezzotint, and so on.
And there's a very neat
full-screen view for the primary
thing, and there's,
if you use the arrow keys
on your computer you can
cycle through.
Have to be on the surface.
You can cycle through
all the magnifications
and all the views,
and change whether you're looking at it
from a 45 degree angle,
from a zero degree angle,
and from a 90 degree angle.
So it's a pretty, it's an
interesting virtual print shop,
or a virtual lab where you could study
prints under the microscope and really
really begin to explore
their characteristics.
And the third view in here
is called identification.
That's a single page that, um,
takes you through...
Hmm.
This is not Graphics Atlas's fault.
(audience laughs)
But what we will do is, um,
start from home in case it
is Graphics Atlas's fault.
So if you wanted to find
out how to identify a,
for example, an inkjet print,
you can do that here.
So there's a single page telling you
all about the key
characteristics of inkjet prints.
Different dot structures
that they might have,
different back printing.
There's your little video of
this particular inkjet print,
and talking about abrasion, and so on, so.
As some of you may know
Bamber Gascoigne's book,
How to Identify Prints.
This is a kind of electronic
version of that very thing,
and I think it's very good
for classroom teaching,
and so on, so.
Thank you for indulging
me on that commercial.
GraphicsAtlas.org.
And now, to the main event.
Sustainable stewardship.
The subtitle is really the important one,
it's talking about the new
thinking on preservation
environments and building operations.
Are there any building
operators in the audience?
Any bites?
Anybody wants to, you know, be singled out
for building operations?
- [Audience Member] Sort of.
- [James] Sort of?
(laughs) Well, everyone,
everyone has a house,
so they're building
operators for that, but.
Anyway, let's plunge on.
This is what Bobby told you about us
at the Image Permanence Institute.
And let me take the opportunity
to acknowledge the sponsors.
NEH, IMLS, Andrew W. Mellon Foundation,
and the Society for Imaging
Science and Technology.
They are the people that have made
IPI and all of its work possible.
What I'm gonna try to do
in the next little while is
talk about some of the ideas that have
become current in our work
and the work of others.
Concepts, talk about some
of the tools and approaches
to managing environments, and
focus in on a couple of projects that
we have been involved in.
Major ones at the Library of Congress.
There's a project that we're embarking on
here at Yale University
that is funded by IMLS.
In that project we will be
exploring the concept of saving energy
by shutting off air handlers
during unoccupied hours
in library stack spaces.
And our sandbox for this
particular fun day at the beach
will be the stacks here
in Sterling Library,
which are served by six
different air handling units.
We'll be having fun with that.
I will also tell you
about a similar experiment
that we have begun at
the Library of Congress.
And then I wanted to share with you
the opportunity to take a look at some
new museum storage buildings
that are extremely low energy
that have been built in Denmark.
I could go on about them
for a very long time,
but we'll get to that.
Every, here's a little,
part of this is gonna be a
primer on this whole subject.
I recently had the opportunity to
visit 10 historically black
colleges and universities
to consult with them on
the environments in their
special collections
departments of their libraries.
And this is the library at
Prairie View A&M University
in suburban Houston, Texas.
It's a nice new building.
It's got great collections,
was built in the 1980s.
And this view has a little
symbolic thing going on
because one of the things
that you need to know
about this whole subject is that
the outside climate is
hugely determinative of
what the inside climate is like,
what are the possibilities
for saving energy?
And the two things that combine
to create the inside climate
are the outside climate
and the mechanical systems
inside the building.
Just pause to review some of
the real fundamentals, here.
When you build a structure,
and have systems to control
the climate inside it,
it's fairly easy to control temperature.
The machines to make cold and to make heat
are easy to build and easy to control.
The tough job is controlling moisture.
And that's what we want to do in library,
and archive, and museum environments
is we want control over both
temperature and moisture.
And it's the moisture part
that's really the difficult one.
And here is where the complexity
with the outdoor climate
comes into play.
We pay a lot of attention
in environmental management
to this parameter called dew point.
Now dew point is the temperature at which
moisture will condense out of the air.
But dew point is also a direct measure
of the amount of moisture in air.
And since there's often
too little moisture
in the outside air or too much
moisture in the outside air,
depending on the season, what you,
how much outside air that
comes into your building,
and whether it's the right
quantity of moisture,
it has the right dew point,
that's where the details get devilish.
And the more outside air,
here's a little energy note,
just in general, you save
energy by not running machinery.
And when you're bringing
in more outside air,
and especially when, in
the heart of the summer,
or the heart of the winter, when it's
too cold and too dry, or
too warm and too moist,
that's when you spend a lot of money.
The more work you work you
have to do on outside air,
the worse it is for energy.
Well, as far as the
collection is concerned,
and we're back again,
here, at Prairie View A&M,
in that building.
If you go down to the
basement of that building,
that's where you see machines like this
that make the environment
inside the building.
This is what's called
an air handling unit.
And what you're looking at is,
it's a big sheet-metal box,
there's a fan the middle,
straddling each side, in
this particular case, is,
are these pipes, and behind
and inside the machine is
a cooling coil, and a
heating coil, and a fan.
Those are the real fundamental elements.
And it's this machine's job
to provide a human-comfort environment,
and to provide a suitable
environment for the collections.
This is a rare sight.
I'm gonna show you one of the
rarest sights you've ever seen.
There you see a meeting of the minds
between the library director
and the building operator,
together, in the mechanical rooms.
And you're gonna hear from me that
the thesis of my work
is that the preservation
of the collection depends hugely
on the storage conditions.
I could talk 'til you are
all bleeding at the eardrums
about the ways in which (laughs)
temperature and humidity conditions
really do affect the conditions.
But if you'll simply grant me that,
if the jury will stipulate that,
we can go on to talking
about the other stuff, okay?
And so here you see,
here you see what ideally has to happen.
My thesis will be that we can no longer,
if we're preservation or
we're in the collections part
of a cultural institution,
we can no longer
be an effective advocate for
the health of our collections
in this way, unless we have a
kind of meeting of the minds.
And it was really funny, the
fellow there had worked there
for 11 years, that'd be
the guy in the blue shirt.
He is explaining
a panel of controls.
The machine I just showed
you, the air handler?
That is controlled via
a computerized system,
and that's like the little junction box
where all the wires that are connected
to individual valves and dampers
go to sort of a concentration point,
and from there they
are sent to a computer.
So this fellow can operate
this library's systems
from his office, which was across campus,
or anyone in the whole
Johnson Controls organization
could be thousands of miles away,
can see what's going on and operate it.
This is what's called a BMS,
or a building management system.
Sometimes called an
energy management system.
The funny part about getting
everybody together to see this,
I insisted that the library
directors and the archivists
go on a tour of the mechanical rooms.
And this was what's so rare about this,
at one moment I said to the
guy here in the blue shirt,
I said, "Wow, I guess this is the biggest,
biggest crowd you've ever had down here?"
And he said, "This is the only crowd
"I've ever had down here."
(audience laughs)
And it was,
I did this 10 times.
And sometimes I had to drag
these library directors
kind of kicking and screaming
through the mechanical rooms.
But it's extremely instructive.
It concretizes what's going on,
and it embodies this idea,
embodies the whole thing.
Now, one of the things you'll hear me say
in just a moment is how
complex these systems are.
And I explain that there,
you know, that there was
a computer somewhere where
you could see and visualize
the moving parts of this, the
building management system.
This is what one part of such
a system would look like.
This is the schematic part,
where every moving part is represented.
And if you look closely,
there are little values there.
This is what the operator of a building
sits at a computer terminal
and looks at screens like that.
Alright, now let's talk
about sustainability
and really get to the fundamentals here.
Environments cost a lot of money.
They burn a lot of energy.
And in many cases that's
fossil fuel energy.
And as a rule of thumb, you can think
for every square foot of temperature
and humidity-controlled space,
an average cost per year,
just for the energy,
not for the salary of the blue shirt guy,
not for the amortized
capital cost of building it,
but just the amount of electric
and gas it burns each year,
is $4 per square foot, on average.
For example, the University
of California Los Angeles
has 850,000 square feet of library stacks,
so you begin to do the math
and you're talking about big big money.
I just showed you an example of
a building management system.
One of the reasons why it's
so rare that preservation,
collections, staff like
librarians and so on,
and facilities staff and
building operators get together,
is everybody's job is
very very complicated.
And from the building side,
the buildings are really
hard to understand,
they're very individualistic,
there are many generations
of those building management systems,
there's band-aids on top of band-aids,
there are dumb systems
designed from the beginning.
There are all kinds of reasons why
understanding them does not come easily.
And no one should underestimate
the reality that it's difficult.
Now, I asked you to stipulate to me
that environments do
matter for the collections.
And the points that are important
in the sustainability context for that are
we've spent a long time, I'm at,
more or less, at the
tail end of my career.
But I've spent at least 30 years
studying the ways in which
materials deteriorate in the laboratory.
Causing them to deteriorate
through accelerated aging.
Reading about deterioration.
Going to conferences,
listening to people talk about
the ways in which collections are
harmed or helped by the environment.
And, what's the net result of all of that?
I can say to you that
most professionals that are
in the preservation field,
or in the curatorial or librarian field
would give less latitude
for safe environments
for collections than I think is real,
than I think the science would support.
In other words, there is more latitude
to do different things
with the environment.
And I'll speak to that
point a little bit later.
But here's a crucial point, as well.
And that is, suppose we wanted to
save some of that big money,
some of the money we're
spending to condition
to precise temperature and
humidity all those square foot
of libraries, of museum
stores, of archival materials.
How are we gonna do that?
What's gonna be the problem
standing in the way?
What's gonna be in the
way is not the ability to
turn things off, because that's
three clicks on the mouse.
You can shut it off
with three mouse clicks
and the password.
That's the easy part, and
that'll save you money.
The hard part is knowing
when to do that safely
and responsibly for your collections.
And who's gonna be
prepared to answer that?
Is it gonna be the facilities person?
No.
Is it gonna be the CFO?
Is it gonna be the director, or the dean,
or the chief curator, or whoever?
No, it's got to be the person who has
the collection's care responsibility.
Be they conservator, preservation
administrator, or so on.
Their guidance is critical.
Their input is critical to achieving
a sustainable condition in
these cutural institutions.
In other words, it ain't
on those buildings guys.
It ain't on the CFO.
It's on the preservation
and conservation function.
And they have got to step
up, and they are the ones
who are gonna describe this envelope
of reasonable safe operation
for the collections.
It might even be better.
Big money?
Well, you be the judge.
This is a woman that's an archivist at
Woodruff Library in Atlanta, and they,
to give you an idea, she's
standing in an air handler.
She's standing in one of those machines
that make the environment.
She's standing in front of a cooling coil
that's 12 feet high
and about 30 feet long.
And there's another one of the same size
directly behind this one.
That machine, the cooling
that runs through that coil
is provided by two
machines, called chillers,
that are of this size.
So, when I say we're
talking about big money,
you don't want to pay the electric bill.
You don't want to pay
the fuel energy costs
for these things.
Okay, so here's where it comes down to.
The scope of my interest and talk is
in sustainability is not
building the greenest,
coolest new thing, but
working with what we have.
And that's going to be the
case for quite a while.
The question for large institutions is,
how do we work with the buildings we have,
the mechanical systems, and
collections that we have?
In other words, we want to optimize them.
And to me this is where sustainability is
defined in practice.
What is optimal operation?
Well, environment is the
best for the collection.
It causes the least deterioration.
It uses the least energy, the least fuel,
natural gas, electricity, and so on.
That it, it's workable for the people
who have to use the collections.
It's workable for the workflows
that the institution has
to actually fulfill its other functions.
The best systems, most
sustainable systems,
are also maintainable and simple.
I cannot tell you how often
things were some designer's
bright idea, and they're turned off.
They're turned off.
People, I just,
I arrived here to find out
that there have been layoffs
in the facilities organization
in this institution.
Recently.
And that's, no, they're not,
you're not alone in that at all.
There's fewer and fewer people.
They're stretched thinner and thinner.
The systems are more and more complicated.
There is a huge premium on simplicity
and maintainability in all this.
And finally, in some
institutions, the structure itself
is part of the collection.
That's true for many
historic homes, and so on.
Whatever the optimal solution is
to operate these massive
energy-hog machines,
it has to work with the structure.
It can't ruin the walls,
the building envelope.
And it has to,
it has to be working in harmony
with the outdoor climate.
Okay, well that's the principles.
Optimal, that's our
mantra and our buzzword.
Optimal operation.
And that was what we set out
to do at the Library of Congress,
with the Mellon Foundation grant in 1999.
And now we're in our eleventh year
of working with the
preventive conservation staff
and the Architect of the Capitol staff
at the Library of Congress.
And I'd like to just share with you
a little bit of what we're doing and
what that has meant, the
lessons we've learned.
The way we've worked at
the Library of Congress is
we work on two fronts.
The energy front, and the collections
environment front, at once.
So we place, we place data loggers,
this device here is called the PEM2,
that's a temperature and
humidity recording device.
It's about this big, and
it's battery-powered,
very portable, and you can
retrieve the data from it
by putting a USB flash drive
into a little port on the side,
and it will write a text
file on that USB flash drive
that tells you the temperature
and humidity conditions.
And so they have approximately
150 such devices scattered
in the three principle buildings
of the Library of Congress
and they tell us what the
collections are experiencing.
At the same time we're measuring
inside selected air handling units,
those machines that make the climate.
And there you see June Wheeler,
by the way, was a partner
in an energy consulting firm
that we have worked with
called Herzog, Wheeler and Associates.
June, by the way, 1981 Yale
alumni in architecture.
Yay, huh?
(audience laughs)
Local girl makes good.
And that is Jeremy
Linden of the IPI staff.
I'm sorry, messing it up here.
And they are, they are
standing outside a large,
but by no means the
largest ever, air handler
that serves exactly half
of the Adams Building.
The Adams Building is the
1934 building on Capitol Hill.
It has 12 stack levels, I
don't know how many million
volumes of books in one
giant block square building,
and there are two air handlers that serve
all those book stacks.
The north unit and the south unit.
So we are measuring the amount of energy
that is consumed by the
south stack air handler.
And what we've been doing is, recently is
turning it off at eight o'clock at night
and turning it on at six
o'clock in the morning.
Shut off, dead, end of story.
There are no staff in there at that time.
And there is,
there is no reason to have ventilation.
Just by dint of this,
we have estimated that
if we did that year-round.
If we turned it off every night,
and turned it on again
every morning, year-round,
it would save, in this unit alone,
$80,000 US dollars in fuel energy.
So between the two units,
if we did it in both sides,
it would be $160,000 per year
just by turning it off at night.
So, and when I say it's
big money and big savings
that are possible, it really is.
But you have to do it safely.
The trick is what happens
when you turn it off.
And in the real world,
sometimes, very little happens.
Happily, so far, that's been the case
in the Adams south stacks.
You can see a tiny little blip,
but we have the ability and the technology
to know what that means
for the collection and
it don't mean much.
So, as long as the collection's
cruisin along happily,
why not put that 80,000 bucks
in your pocket each year?
And, just think, there
are two other buildings
there at the Library of Congress.
One of them, called the
James Madison Building,
is the newest one.
It has 42 air handlers in the penthouse,
and another 16 air
handlers in the basement.
You get the idea.
I mean, I'm not trying
to oversell this, but
there's real money involved,
and it's really worth thinking about.
Well, how do you address
that critical question of
when is the collection,
as a result of anything,
as a result of the phases
of the moons of Jupiter,
or of you turning things off,
or just the way they did it,
or just they way they've always done it.
The problem is one of
prima facie understanding
what the collections are experiencing,
and what that might mean
in terms of deterioration.
And this is a,
this is a,
give you an idea of how that
judgement call has been made
not only here in Sterling,
but in many institutions,
hundreds of different institutions
are using our environmental
assessment methods,
which begin by collecting temperature
and humidity data continuousy.
And, by the way, you ain't
got no data, you just punk.
You know?
What's that, what's that, uh,
what's that saying, you know?
Money talks, and something
else walks, you know?
Data talks, and everything else walks.
If you don't have data, if you don't know
what your collections are experiencing,
you're just kind of out of luck.
Because you can't get to first base.
I know there's a lot of
Red Sox fans here, right?
You'd understand that analogy.
Without temperature and humidity data,
you don't get to first base.
Alright.
So, when you have temperature
and humidity data,
a lot of people think that
they're able to then understand
what the collections are experiencing.
Yeah, right.
That's what we spent 25 years of
research to try to figure out is that
surely there are ways to
take that basic information
about temperature and moisture and then
derive something that's
more meaningful to us that,
that helps us understand
whether it's good or bad,
or precisely how good or
bad it is for collections.
So here's a kind of console
view that you might see.
These are the different spaces.
Here are forms of deterioration
that can affect cultural heritage objects.
Natural aging is slow chemical changes,
that's a big one for libraries.
Mechanical damage, that's due
to the sweling and shrinking.
It's very important for
objects made of wood,
or objects like paintings, or
ivory or bone, or lacquered objects,
things of that kind, where the
relative humidity of the air
determines the moisture
content of the object,
and through a dry winter or a damp summer,
the object will expand and contract.
How much it expands,
how much it contracts,
and how big that excursion
is between its extremes
of expansion and contraction.
Those are parameters which you can use
to manage the environment.
And so, then there's mold growth.
Mold will not grow under many
common environmental conditions.
We all know that damp
conditions promote mold growth.
So, and then finally,
there's metal corrosion,
which, again, requires a
certain amount of moisture.
Well, the sort of console view to tell you
what the collections are experiencing.
One part of it can be boiled down
to idiot lights, like this.
Red, bad.
(audience laughs)
Green, good.
You know, and okay.
Okay.
(audience laughs)
So, you can see it.
You know, you're just
like, "Okay, there it is."
But you, you know, and
it's also dependent on
what period of time
that you're looking at.
If you want a little bit
more nuanced understanding of
how good or bad the environment is
with respect to these
things that are critical
to collections' care, then
you look at these numbers,
which we call the preservation metrics.
And these numbers are derived from the raw
temperature and humidity data.
And each one of them, I'm not
gonna explain them in detail,
but that's the one that
relates to chemical aging.
It's very important for fading of dyes
and degradation of paper.
That's a factor that tells you
whether mold would be possible
and when it's in red, it
says pay attention to me.
These particular spaces
are all problematic
from the natural aging point of view.
One of them is beginning to be problematic
from the mold point of view.
And several of them are problematic
because they get too damp.
But I show you this only that,
to explain that there are ways now to use
quantitative quality control metrics
to control preservation environments.
And when they're in use, they work.
And we've been using
those for a long time.
Now, if you wanna,
here's the really important
lesson that we've learned at LC.
Environ, you know, the people who,
Nobody raised their hand to say they were
a building facilities type person, right?
If you're there, you're
probably going like this now.
(audience laughs)
Let me say something sort of pejorative
and stereotypical about that role.
It's not really
pejorative, it's real life.
If you or I were in that role,
we'd be doing the same thing
which is that, when you
think about environment,
they think about environment as a project.
Environment is, yeah, well we'll
get the equipment to do the job.
They don't think about it the way we,
I think you should approach
it, which is as a process.
Really, facilities people,
it's either a project
that has to be designed and
built and scoped and budgeted,
or it's a trouble call,
or a comfort complaint.
That's all there is.
There's no, like, look at it every day,
see how it's doing.
Or look at it every month, you know?
It's a project, or it's a trouble call,
or it's a human comfort complaint.
And humans can use the telephone
and they can call up
and say, "I'm too hot",
"I'm too cold", and that
will drive the actions.
That's one key feedback mechanism for the
building operators.
But the collections,
they lost the number.
I mean it was so heart-breaking.
(audience laughs)
They lost that building guy's number.
You know, they had it written
down on a Post-it note,
and they stuck it somewhere.
And now it fell off,
and now they, you know,
the books can't call anybody anymore.
So that's, that's, you know,
if you're going to address
and change that circumstance,
it has to, you have to go after it.
It's a process.
It's people getting together and talk.
It's not a numerical
specification, by the way.
Managing an environment is not
is not calling up your buddy
at the other conservation lab
and saying, "well, what do you do?"
"Well, we do 70, 50."
"Okay, that's what I'm gonna
tell the architect we want."
That isn't managing your environment.
It's not a numerical specification.
In fact, no single environment
is best for every kind of object.
So it can't be approached that way.
And really, the way to think
about environmental management
for preservation and sustainability is
by analogy to modern manufacturing.
Think about the way that
automobiles are manufactured.
And, famously, even though Toyota's
having a lot of problems lately (laughs),
people in the, do you know,
did you read that in the paper?
People still buy Toyotas, okay?
They're not, they're not hurtin.
Akio Toyota is not about to commit seppuku
because his gas pedals stuck a little bit.
They still sell them and
people still buy them, why?
Because they're really well made.
And the manufacturing prowess
of Japan is well known.
And they invented these concepts
of continuous improvement in many cases.
And if you're in modern manufacturing,
modern manufacturing
is done on these ideas
that it's never finished.
It's a process of continuous examination
of the production line, of the costs
that goes into producing the product.
It's a constant reassessment
of quality control.
And if we could make that analogy,
the environment is something
that's manufactured every day,
down there, those machines, those AHUs,
they're not stamping out widgets,
they're stamping out temperature
and humidity conditions.
And if we don't pay attention
to how they're working,
we're not gonna ever get any better.
So, what's preservation's role in this
modern manufacturing process,
if we can make that analogy?
The preservation role is as designer,
because, after all,
it's not the facilities,
it's not the library directors,
it's the preservation
and conservation role
to say what the environment should be.
To lay out its key points.
And then it's up to other
people to manufacture it.
But then they have another key role,
which is quality control,
which is what I just showed
you with using the metrics.
And you know what?
Metrics are found in every
area of manufacturing.
And you can't improve
automobile production lines
unless you have some
way of measuring defects
and reducing them.
And, so, you're part of a production team
if you're in the preservation world.
And that production team
is making the environment.
Whose goal is optimal operation.
Remember all those things
working together in harmony?
You know, woo.
It just gives me goosebumps
to think about it.
(audience laughs)
But the participants in this process are
the collection care professionals,
the building operators themselves,
the people who love
and own the collection,
the curators, librarians,
archivists, and the staff,
and then the administrators
who oversee the whole thing,
including the money people.
And they all together share
the responsibilities for
stewardship of the collections,
for cost control, because
people are getting laid off
because these systems are
chewing up too much money,
and for sustainability in the sense of
being a responsible global citizen.
I mean, it should bother everyone that
unnecessary, if there's
unnecessary energy waste,
it is harming the planet.
And it is spending money that
could be used for much better things.
I had to throw this in!
You know, I, I'm a former English major,
and I love that analogy of manufacturing,
you know, and continuous improvement.
And today I got this email
and I and to throw it in here.
At RIT, where I work, you know,
there was an email advertising
RIT's Lean Six Sigma
Yellow Belt Certification Program.
Now, have you all had that
conversation with somebody
and you're saying, well what do you do?
And they say "I'm a six sigma black belt."
(audience laughs)
You never had that conversation?
(laughs)
(audience laughs)
Well, let me break this down for you.
Okay, well, you know what lean is.
You know, lean is like in manufac,
this is manufacturing jargon.
And this is where manufacturing is.
If you want, you know,
we're a school that teaches
real place manufacturing,
as much as we've got left in this country.
You know, and lean
manufacturing means you're,
you don't have any unnecessary parts,
inventory, and all of that.
Six sigma, everybody
in tune with six sigma?
How many sigmas you got here?
(laughs)
Do you, do you have, seriously,
everybody not know what six sigma is?
How many people not
know what six sigma is?
(audience murmurs)
Oh, god, you people are
hopelessly out of touch.
(audience laughs)
- [Woman] Yeah.
- [James] Yeah.
When you do real quality
control and you have those
measurements of quality
like you're making widgets,
six sigma means,
sigma is the, is the,
is the measure of the number
of wrongly-manufactured parts,
for the sake of thinking about it.
And six sigma is
0.00001%
of parts are made in a defective manner.
So if you're six sigma,
like if you work for
Motorola making cellphones,
Motorola is obsessed with six sigma.
There are people whose,
whose careers are six sigma.
And so many so that
they had to have, like,
six sigma newbie, you know,
white, white, you know,
and it's like the dojo where
you're learning karate.
(audience laughs)
First, you get the robe and
you feel all self-conscious.
And, you know, and then you
get, what's the first belt
you get white belt or something?
And then you progress up
through brown belt, yellow belt,
and if you're black
belt, and then you know.
So, like this, this
program here that they're
advertising in emails
in my campus, is like,
"Yeah, you can sign up
for this three-day course
"to learn how to do quality control
"so that you are at
0.00001 defects", okay?
So that, manufacturing today does embody,
if you read through
the text at the bottom,
it does embody complicated
things done cooperatively.
And my thesis here in this talk is that
that's the way I see
institutional preservation
and sustainability
programs working together.
To understand that it's a process.
To understand people's responsibilities
and people hold up their end of the deal.
It's absolutely hopeless, by the way,
to expect that facilities people
would understand collections
care and preservation.
But they need to know enough about it
that they can function
as part of the team.
And therefore, we as,
Oh, well, this is Chip and Kevin.
This is part of the Library
of Congress project, too.
I mean when we first
started there in 1999,
we did not have wondrous cooperation
from the building
operators, but now we do.
And it's really proof that, I mean,
now when we work there,
and these guys take care
of the Adams building,
and they are the front
lines of the sustainability
in the Library of Congress
in this respect that
if anybody's gonna save the $80,000,
it's gonna be Chip and Kevin.
And they have to understand
what's going on, and
and they do, and it's a real
pleasure to work with them.
So, I know the process can work.
And the man on the right
in the black is, there,
that's Peter Herzog.
He's the energy specialist on our team.
And the person on the left
is, works at IPI, Jeremy.
He'll be working here in Sterling.
They are standing in that
air handler that serves
Adams south, and that gives you some idea
that that is a large
machine, and indeed it is.
And that is Ben Bauman.
He's the preservation
liaison for the project.
And he's pointing to
one of our data loggers
that is helping us to understand
when the system goes on and goes off.
So, I wanted to emphasize
that the preservation role
in this, you don't have
to know what these,
you don't have to know the building
so well you could fix everything.
You don't have to know the
energy saving part so well
that you can puzzle out the BTUs.
But you have to know
enough to be a team player
And you do have to take possession
of gathering data and using these metrics.
And you do have to know
enough about your collection
to know what its particular needs are.
And you can't just read
it in a book, and so on.
That's the data logger
I was talking about.
Now I'm gonna beat up for
a while on the need to
to have a close idea of quality control.
Most people who collect
temperature and humidity data
just see it graphed like this,
which is impossible to
understand and analyze.
Yes, if you've been doing it for 15 years,
you get some idea.
But it's a far cry from
what I just showed you.
And a lot of people's idea
about the environment,
and this comes from the museum world,
is that the ideal environment
for collections is
very steady, it's about
70 degrees Fahrenheit,
comfortable for humans, and
then doesn't vary very much.
And it's 50% RH, kind of the
middle of the humidity range,
and it doesn't vary more
than, say, 5% up or down.
That, you might say, is the
current museum standard.
Next Monday and Tuesday is a meeting,
a very high-level summit meeting,
at the Museum of Fine Arts in Boston
by museum conservators and others.
I will, I'll be attending,
I'll probably have to wear a helmet, but
I will be attending (laughs).
The whole idea is that even for the
real high end art museums,
this hand-me-down standard is not,
is under attack, it's not workable.
It is good for one thing.
70 degrees, 50% RH is
not the ideal environment
for your collection.
It has, however, one
absolutely useful feature.
If you're gonna be exhibiting stuff,
it's convenient for the visitors
who come to the exhibit.
And if you're gonna be putting
different types of objects together,
the 50% RH level is
probably the best compromise
for showing different kinds of objects.
But that's as far as its
beauty and wonderment go.
Because, as the next dot says,
it's mad money for most climates.
It really is very expensive.
It's kind of the enemy of sustainability.
Because if that's the way,
if that's your position,
you want it steadily
70 degrees and 50% RH,
you're kind of locked out
of the sustainability game.
And you're paying mad money for that.
Mad money in the street sense
of that's a lot of money.
And mad money in the
other sense of mad, like,
you're mad if you do that.
Because of, you know, bah!
And it's in, like I say,
it's incompatible with
sustainable operations.
And here in a library,
70, 50 is really bad
for library collections.
Because it's too warm,
you're cooking the books.
I talked about the metrics.
They really allow you to do that.
And I wanted to point out another website
that's very instructive called dpcalc.org.
And this is a website that we created
where you can explore
the inner relationship
between temperature,
humidity, and dew point.
And you can see on the right-hand side,
those idiot lights and the
values of those metrics,
and you can see how there is
no one perfect environment.
There's a continuum.
And some environments are better for
preserving objects that
might degrade through
spontaneous chemical change,
like paper and textiles.
Some environments are better for,
for other kinds of materials,
or assemblages of materials.
And you can explore that here.
It's a very good teaching tool.
Tara was saying to me.
Tara Kennedy, the preservation
field services officer
here at Sterling, was
saying to me just today,
this is, if you don't know this,
you don't know nothing (laughs).
(audience laughs)
Because this is the
fundamental relationships
that guide the whole thing,
whether you're trying
to make the environment
or you're trying to understand it.
Anyway, the bottom line,
in our 11 years at LC,
and there you see Nancy Lev-Alexander,
who is the, the,
preventive conservation
supervisor at the library,
together with Peter Herzog
and Ben, who works for Nancy.
And they, the lesson
that we've learned is,
remember going back to
that optimal operation?
If you think that your place might be,
by chance, optimal already?
(laughs) Forget about it.
(audience laughs)
Just forget about it.
That's one thing we've
seen over and over again
is that you can safely
assume it's not optimal
unless you've really looked at
it and tried to make it that.
The last thing I wanted to share with you
was a new idea,
that is particular, really,
I think to museum objects,
and particular to certain climates,
but it's very interesting from
the low-energy point of view.
The Danes, when the Arab Oil
embargo hit in the 1970s,
there were,
the Danes had a reaction like,
oh, we gotta save energy from now on.
And they've been at it ever since
in a very very serious way.
Our reaction was,
ah, gee, there's a long line
at the gas station (laughs).
(audience laughs)
I can't wait 'til that's over.
Oh, it's over!
Okay!
And we went on, happily
ignoring the whole darn thing.
And, you know, it's interesting
to see what you could do
if you didn't do that.
And at the National Museum of Denmark,
they have a group of
scientists and engineers
that work exclusively with the idea
of designing buildings from the ground up
that are storage for
archives and museum objects
and they used very very little energy.
And I wanted to show you two of them.
One of them is in the
town of Vejle in Denmark.
It is a museum storage building
that is a cooperative
of among seven museums.
And then its son or daughter,
or whatever you wanna call it,
another building for another
museum in another town
that was designed along
the same principles.
So, hey, you know you're not in Kansas
when you see a building like this, right?
This is the Vejle Cooperative Storehouse.
(clears throat) Doesn't look like much.
It's not winning any
awards for landscaping
I don't think, either.
Um, it's not exactly the
architectural triumph of the,
of Europe, but that's what
it looks like on the outside.
(clears throat) The really
cool part, and this is
what it looks like on the inside.
It's 600 square meters of,
about 30 feet high ceilings.
It's a one-story building.
It needs to be to be the kind of
very low-energy building that it is.
I'll explain that in a second.
But that gives you a feeling for the
kind of objects that are there.
The Vejle environment is completely,
the environment inside
it is a prize-winner.
On our metrics, and by any estimation,
it is a real,
it's a champ.
The RH is steady at
about 55% all year long.
The temperature varies.
This is a basic design.
The RH is steady, and
the temperature varies.
And the temperature goes
from about 45 degrees
inside in winter, to about
65 degrees in summer.
And there are never any violent
spikes in relative humidity
because the interior
walls, which are made of a
special concrete, and the
collections themseves,
to some degree buffer
the relative humidity.
Here's some of the secrets
to making this building
do its magic.
It has no outside air.
There's no intentionally-introduced
outside air.
From leakage, to doors opening, and so on,
there have a measured it to be
about 1-1/2 air changes per day.
So, the inside air is
replaced by outside air
only 1-1/2 times a day.
Does that sound like a lot to you?
A building like this?
Probably undergoes 17 to
20 air changes per day.
The room we're in.
So, that's very low.
And as far as quality goes,
the TWPI is over 100.
Here in Sterling, most of
the TWPIs are about 50, 55.
There's very little dimensional change
because the RH hardly varies
at all throughout the year.
There's no mold because
55% RH won't stand,
won't support mold.
And here's the punchline.
Here's the money shot.
Total energy cost?
$3 per kilowatt-hour,
$3 per kil,
Okay, I'm screwing up my money line.
(audience laughs)
To operate the building,
it costs $3
per cubic meter,
per year.
And that, um,
I think, yeah, I mis-labeled the slide.
But it's $3 per cubic meter.
Now, it's a floor area
of 600 square meters,
and it's 30 feet high,
so, you get the idea.
But that is peanuts.
It is peanuts.
And another concern when.
Okay, if you all your museum objects
in a closed box like this,
how come, it, it.
Doesn't foul its own nest?
Doesn't the collection
objects produce pollutants?
And by careful selection,
you'll notice it has,
it's basically all metal,
except for the collections.
All metal and concrete.
All the finishes are selected
so they don't outgas.
So it doesn't foul its
own nest with pollutants.
And they have actually
made these measurements.
This is a slide that came from those guys.
And here's the mechanical room
for this very large building.
It has a tiny little
desiccant dehumidifier.
This thing.
There is an air handler.
It's a little bit
different scale air handler
as the ones I've been showing you.
And it has no cooling.
The building has no cooling,
there is no way to cool the building.
The building is cooled
because it sits on the ground.
And in the winter the concrete
floor adds a little heat.
And in the summer, the
concrete floor acts as a sink
for heat, it actually cools the building.
Now, part of the secret
of this building is
it works in the Danish climate, which is
cool and damp and somewhat cloudy.
(laughs)
I think the colors from
Twilight, you know?
After they left Forks, the
Cullens moved here to Copenhagen.
You gotta watch, you gotta go to movies
and read teenage novels to
get that joke, but anyway.
It's cold, and it's damp,
but it doesn't get real cold,
and it doesn't get real hot, either.
And that's, you know,
that's a similar climate
to much of the northwest of
the United States, by the way.
And so this air handler
merely stirs the air around.
There's a fan with a tiny motor,
there is a heating coil in there,
but it doesn't go on hardly at all.
And, in fact, the heat
generated by the air dryer
is enough to both heat and
dehumidify the building.
And the lights are off most of the time.
There's no one in there most of the time.
And, like I said, it just sips energy.
And here's a building that
was built along the same lines
with slightly different
materials in a town called Ribe.
And this, give you an idea
that's the relative humidity,
here the dehumidifier failed.
But it's flat 55% of the time.
This is just when the dehumidifier is on.
Here's the temperature
floating with the seasons,
cooler in the winter,
slightly warmer but never hot
in the summer.
Remember, they gotta
climate that doesn't get
too hot in the summer or
too cold in the winter.
But there are ideas
about this that could be
adapted to many places in the US.
And this is the energy used
by the dehumidifier, so,
a very very interesting building.
Here's from their own scientists,
these are the keys to
building a building like that.
They say low winter
temperature is a benefit.
But it doesn't get low by our standards.
And that's good, because they would have
to begin to add moisture if it did.
Dehumidification, they find, is cheaper
than humidistatic heating.
The low ventilation rates,
the fact that the
building is fairly tight,
keeps the outdoor pollutants out.
And, yet, inside it's not fouled by
collection-generated pollutants.
Although, you do have to pay attention
to what you make the building out of.
And here is the key, the
slab, the concrete floor
is doing all the work of
heating and cooling it,
and they've discovered
that it's important that
the floor not be insulated, but the walls,
the side walls and roof be
insulated very well, thermally.
So we come back and look
at our own buildings,
I think there's lots of
lessons and lots of opportunity
for sustainability improvements.
And if you wanna,
last thing I wanna show you is this little
things to look at to
save energy in a building
like we have, and like most
of our libraries and museums.
Keys are you're not gonna save money
unless you undertand how the systems work.
Typically, there are
low-hanging fruit opportunities.
The things that consume energy are
cooling the air and heating it back up
when you don't have to
in order to dehumidify
when you don't have to.
Running your fans too much,
and letting in too much outside air.
Use the preservation metrics to really
regulate the whole thing.
Thank you very much for coming.
I hope I didn't go too long.
I did go too long, I'm sorry.
(audience murmurs)
So, if you want to, if
you absolutely loved this,
if this was riveting to you.
I mean, I know you're on
the edge of your seat, like
what can I do now?
(audience member laughs)
(laughs)
Then you can go to our website,
imagepermanenceinstitute.org
and sign up for our exciting
climate notes newsletter,
which is a quarterly
newsletter, e-newsletter
that discusses a lot of
these topics in detail.
So, thank you very much.